After months of speculation, Alien: Covenant
has finally been unleashed upon the world
in all its gory glory.
Whatever your feelings are about the return
to the franchise, there are still some considerable
inconsistencies in the story to discuss.
That's why we've rounded some plot holes you
could fit a chestburster through.
"Hello my baby, hello my honey, hello my
ragtime gal!"
But before you keep watching, just be aware:
there are major spoilers ahead, so please...tread
carefully.
Not like that guy.
That guy's dead.
Not so handy
Alien: Covenant's big plot twist at the end
comes with the reveal that it's actually the
nefarious David aboard the ill-fated Covenant,
not his kinder synthetic "brother" Walter.
In order for David to effectively fool the
surviving crew, he must assume Walter's identity
completely, and that includes cutting off
his hair… and one of his hands.
Walter notably lost his own hand while protecting
Daniels earlier in the film, but something
about that doesn't completely add up.
When Walter and David duke it out on the surface
of the planet, we learn that Walter's been
built with self-healing technology, allowing
him to recover from being fatally stabbed
in the neck.
So if he can recover from mortal injuries
in minutes...why can't he heal a dismembered
limb over the course of the film?
Sure, regrowing a hand is probably tough...but
so is coming back from the dead.
Safety first
Sci-fi and action films have caused us to
become accustomed to watching smart characters
do incredibly dumb things for our entertainment.
And Alien: Covenant is no exception.
From Oram sticking his head somewhere no reasonable
person would ever even want to approach, to
the crew following David into the cave of
nightmares he calls a home, the movie is loaded
with maddeningly stupid moments.
But the decision that stands out among all
the others is the one that sees the entire
crew not bothering to don helmets once they've
landed on the Engineers' planet.
This is a foreign, unstudied ecosystem, and
there's no guarantee the humans will be able
to, or even should, breathe the air there.
The lack of protective gear leaves a pretty
convenient entry point for the death spores
into unsuspecting characters' ears and noses.
But logically speaking, nobody would set foot
on an uncharted planet without first making
sure they were completely protected from the
elements, even if the biggest threat is basically
the world's worst pollen allergy.
What came first?
It's very clearly established in Aliens that
the Queen lays the eggs.
Both very simple, and very gross.
But the over-complicated explanations for
the creatures' beginnings, first introduced
in Prometheus, are further built upon here.
Alien: Covenant reveals it was actually David
who created them in the first place, Doctor
Frankenstein-style.
Ten years in isolation makes a man do weird
things with eggs.
But how did he engineer them without the Queen?
Did he create the Queen too?
Is he the creator of all alien lifeforms...or
just some?
David spends years cross-breeding the neomorphs
in pursuit of a more perfect organism, and
by the end of Alien: Covenant, we see the
familiar xenomorph — the end result of all
that experimentation.
But if the events of Alien take place about
20 years later, how did the Space Jockey ship
in that movie end up being filled with eggs?
The more we learn about this mythology, the
less sense it makes.
Pod people problems
The catalyst for Alien: Covenant's ongoing
nightmare is an energy surge, which forces
the ship's crew out of hypersleep early.
Unfortunately, not everybody makes it out
of their sleep pods in time and Captain Jacob
Branson catches on fire and dies.
"I'm just burnin' up."
But what actually happened to his pod?
Did it just malfunction?
Did it have something to do with the energy
surge?
Can they maybe invent a pod that doesn't double
as a barbecue?
Or did Covenant just want to give a little
gift to the audience in the form of James
Franco's smoldering corpse?
"I have a very good life."
Either way, thank you, movie.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!